mask mandate is still in place here in  nevada right now and many people have  made their own  cloth face coverings now there's some  new research revealing a bit more about  those homemade masks so it says  layers are key when it comes to  coverings more layers of course mean  less droplets being dispersed  from the nose and mouth  two layers is much better than one layer  and one layer is much better than  nothing so a proper fit also matters  your mask should cover your nose and  mouth and fit snugly against the sides  of your face  experts of course remind everyone along  with wearing a mask still important to  wash your hands and maintain  social distance